Hey guys, a ton of people have been reaching
out to me telling me they're being automatically
unsubscribed from our YouTube Channel, or
letting me know they're no longer seeing our
videos in their feed.
If you haven't seen any of our videos lately,
I promise you, we're not on a break, we're
still releasing at least one full interview
per week, and oftentimes more.
Make sure you're signed up for notifications
wherever you may watch The Rubin Report to
check out our new content as it's released!
For YouTube viewers, double check to make
sure you're subscribed, and click the bell
icon by the subscribe button to get alerts
as videos are posted.
If you play along on Facebook, make sure you've
both liked and followed The Rubin Report and
Dave Rubin, or if Twitter is your thing, give
me a follow @RubinReport.
And, last but not least, if you prefer to
listen via podcast, The Rubin Report is available
on an array of players, including Apple, Stitcher,
Spotify, or, just subscribe to our RSS feed
in whatever app you prefer, link is in the
description below.
And, of course, if you want to check out some
premium content in addition to our regular
interviews, head over to patreon.com/RubinReport
and sign up to be a monthly supporter.
We've built a really cool, interactive community
over there that I'm truly proud of, and there's
a ton of great perks and bonuses at a variety
of donation levels.
No matter how you consume The Rubin Report,
my team and I thank you for your continued
support, and we look forward to bringing you
even more exciting and diverse content and
conversation in the future.